oh playing g space but without the g
i'm just playing space okay
uh well i'm white let's play a stone
wall
i haven't played the stone wall
oh i can't play stonewall oh it's it's a
england
it's unbeatable amman hamilton
england gambit of greatness wait a
minute
i could trick my opponents let's trick
my opponent
bam now i'm going to play a danish
gambit
takes here it takes here takes here
let's go danish gambit time
unexpected danish gambit take my pawn i
just want the
the two bishops of goodness what is h6
oh h6 is preventing knight g5
i should probably take but let's have
have some fun
just leave the tension
okay now i should really take
but let's have some more fun push the
pawn
oh this is rated blitz
opponent wants to farm me
yeah if i if i win i don't gain any
points but if i lose
i probably lose like 20 points
oh d5 is actually probably a principled
move
i mean i want to take and then rookie 1
but then there's bishop e6
so i could play bishop b5
and 94 takes takes takes
and d5 is a good move
actually debating to take on croissant
what to do
let's play bishop b5 keep the tension
making black make a decision here
knight has a few options thank you
parmal up
subbing for three months okay so this is
um
this is nice to see i think the night
was much better here
is it over there oh it's time
to move quicker because i'm down on time
also it's 5 23 am so
i'm awake i'm alive
so i actually i have two different types
of tea i have this tea which is kind of
still brewing i also have
i bought a new kind of thermos thing and
this has she i made like a while ago
but it's still kind of warm uh
that's a decent move
black's breaking the pin wants to win
the pawn
i could win this pawn for free
yeah everything in life is free
as long as it's not defended so i'm
defending this pawn
and i'm threatening to play this to trap
the knight
and it's unfortunate for black that the
pawn in h6 took away the
the only real retreating square
okay and time is leveling out that's
good
i mean this is uh this is a real threat
and even though my queen is kind of just
oh
as i say my my queen is exposed but it's
hard to attack
but black found a way to attack it
whoa it's bits it's for john history
drinker i
know oh well thank you thanks for the
1500 bits i appreciate that
okay this is a fork
this is really nice
the best tea drinker
what makes me the best
can i be better at drinking tea than
other people
i probably drink more tea than the
average person
oh wait what oh the knights defended
man i wanted to take the night for free
but now i probably have to trade queens
against my will
that's unfortunate
wait a minute am i winning i'm winning
the night oh
oh tactics the so this thing still
exists
and the knight's traps i mean if black
takes takes takes rookie one
f6 and then f4 bam
my tactics gods are on on my side
that's a nice combination now i just
have to not flag
um let's go for the attack
knight b5 maybe you can take
take again go after d6
oh g-space is fast
or maybe not fast enough
good game that was an interesting kind
of weird game
england gambit turns into danish gambit
attempted but
it wasn't quite a real danish hey there
eric first time catching the stream
hopefully you are doing well do you have
any
learning tips on what to focus on for
beginning chess players
thanks a lot less than three
lesson three hahaha i can try and answer
that i would like to send you t but it's
too expensive to send
something into the us oh
well eventually i'll travel
internationally
it was a long time since the last one
oh yeah thanks thanks for the game g
space i appreciate it
uh yeah i know international shipping
can be
a pain but i'll keep people
i'll keep people posted next time i
travel internationally
and if i travel to a city near you maybe
i can uh accept the gift of t
um what was the question oh first time
catching the stream
normal is it normal bass or normal bass
first of all thanks for the bits welcome
to twitch
uh do i have any learning tips on what
to focus on for beginning chess players
um if you're a beginning chess player so
assuming you know the rules
but maybe don't know much beyond that
or maybe are just sub like a thousand
elo
um tactics tactics tactics and play a
lot of games
and try and play like good players
you're going to lose a lot in the
beginning but
the the more you play the more you'll
kind of internalize
and when you play good players you'll
hopefully learn a lot more
um but i definitely recommend
having some resource when it comes to
tactics
um leachate has a nice feature there um
i think of the practice
i'll give you this is a good starting
point if you just want some
kind of foundational exercises like
check meeting patterns basic tactics
um there's a designated books too
i do have a list of book recommendations
on my website
um one book i i like to recommend
for kids but also for adults that's
geared towards beginning players
is um jeff coakley's winning chess
strategy
for kids um
and there's like cartoon images but it
does a good job of like breaking down
uh kind of essential basics has a lot of
good tactics
training as well so
hopefully that provides some some
direction
also thanks so much see the latter month
gifting a sub to normal
i'm just going to go with bass like the
fish
thanks so much appreciate that
and pm amico
thanks for subbing at tier one
anyway um
this game might be youtube worthy just
given the weird opening
given this like interesting tactical
sequence
uh so this
so when i played this i honestly thought
i was winning the night not realizing
the bishop was defending
so that's probably a sign i should get
sleep eventually
um but then it kind of worked out
watch you on youtube consistently oh
nice
oh thanks so much vibov
with five dollars
that's nice to hear yeah i know a lot of
people maybe watch on youtube
more so than twitch a lot of people
discover the twitch channel from youtube
so welcome to the youtube people
and hello to the youtube people watching
in the future
the video is probably about to end but
before it ends you can click
click subscribe click like leave a
comment or question
it helps it definitely helps the channel
helps push the video to new viewers